all right hello everyone welcome to
another episode of Science and
Technology q a for kids and others
I thought maybe this time I would try
and emphasize questions about a
particular topic and I thought the topic
we'd pick is the future
um but I see there are a bunch of other
interesting questions that already come
in and uh maybe I could try and address
some of those first he says hopefully
um
the question
from Leo
uh
could every exoplanet have a habitable
zone if you can get just far enough away
from the Star what makes a planet
habitable
well okay
so
when we talk about habitable we probably
mean to Life as we know it here on Earth
and we certainly don't know what the
kind of General version of what life is
like
anywhere might be I think the thing that
is characteristic of life as opposed to
other kinds of systems is life is sort
of doing what seems to us like kind of
meaningful molecular scale computation
it's moving all those molecules around
in ways that sort of
in some sense make sense to us but it's
kind of a circular thing because we are
examples of that life too and so the
fact that those things that sort of make
sense to us but we are an example of
that kind of life it's not clear that's
a a general way to define things
and the one thing we can say for sure is
there a sort of complicated things going
on in living systems but there are
plenty of complicated things going on in
other systems whether it's turbulent
fluids or or geology or wherever else
that we don't usually think of as being
systems that are alive and when it comes
to life on Earth there's a lot of kind
of historical connection between all
different uh examples of life on Earth
all life on Earth has just one idea
about how to be constructed out of
proteins specified ultimately by by RNA
at least
and so all life on Earth even though
there may be many different kinds of
sort of molecular computation that could
be done all specific life on Earth is
based on very particular molecules like
RNA
um that make it work and once you have
those particular molecules you're pretty
constrained in things like the
environment the kinds of you know do you
have water do you have liquid water do
you have temperatures in a certain range
those kinds of things we know that there
is some extreme life on Earth so-called
extremophiles for example that live in
hydrothermal vents full of sulfur and
things like that in the deep ocean we
don't know for example how deep life
goes under the surface of the Earth for
example we don't know we pretty much
know there's no life in the upper
atmosphere
um
so there's a certain range in which life
with its chemical composition as we have
it here on Earth can exist and uh and
and also a certain uh environment with
things like water that um that are used
there so the question would be if you've
got some random exoplanet around some
other star does it have on it a re at
least a region that is habitable in that
sense that has the appropriate range of
temperatures and chemical compositions
and so on to support life of the kind we
know on on Earth
and um
there are different forms in which that
could occur I mean for example on Earth
we have life existing and things like
our oceans in things like the atmosphere
and so on
um but one could imagine other planets
for example where there's you know a
layer of ice and there's an ocean
underneath the ice
um Enceladus I guess a moon of Saturn
um has the potential to have uh sort of
a an under the ice ocean so to speak
which could be uh for example warmed by
uh well I think in that particular case
probably not but in general such things
could be warmed by radioactive decay and
things like that in the in the inner uh
planetary object
so
there are even sort of knowing oh
there's a planet in this position and it
has this material visible on its in its
atmosphere or on its surface
um even that isn't enough to tell one oh
there can't be anything uh sort of in
the right range that exists in in sort
of an ocean underneath the layer of ice
or Caverns deep inside the planet or
some such other thing so hard to know
that but in terms of kind of an
environment that's a bit like what we
have on Earth there's a certain uh given
a star of a certain size and and the so
so Stars typically go through this
evolutionary sequence most stars go
through the so-called main sequence of
uh uh of stages
um our sun is a g-type star that's sort
of more or less in the middle of the
main sequence
um and a star of a given Mass uh will go
through that a particular sequence of of
evolutionary steps so for example very
big stars will often go through the
evolution in just a few million years as
opposed to something like the sun which
has like a 10 billionaire lifespan
um and uh the um at different times in
the in the history of the star the star
will produce different amounts of of
heat and light and other uh and and sort
of uh amounts of energy it will it will
be generating different amounts of
energy and radiating them out and so a
planet would have to be a different
distance away to sort of have the same
total amounts of heat for example
reaching it as the Earth does from the
Sun
but for most I I think it's probably
true is it right I would think so that
uh for any size of star that will be a
star and things uh you can get Stars
maybe down to I don't know perhaps a
tenth the size of the sun maybe a little
bit smaller I'm not sure
um but by the time the thing gets too
small it won't have this sort of
gravitational effect necessary to
actually sort of push its constituents
together to start nuclear fusion and to
make it actually uh act like a star
it'll just be a something just a cold
blob like a big planet instead so I
think it it's true that for all things
that will make stars there is a distance
away from the star that a planet could
be orbiting at which it will have the
same amount of radiation from of of heat
for example from the star that the Earth
has from the Sun
so that that's one thing so another
thing is that there is certainly an
effect you know the Earth's axis is
tilted 23 degrees relative to the plane
on which it orbits the Sun and that's
what causes us to have seasons and so on
there are places on the Earth where sort
of the the um the surface of the Earth
at a particular season is tilted in such
a way that it's getting sort of the full
heat from the Sun and at another another
season that uh place on the surface of
the Earth is kind of uh at a diagonal
away from the Sun and so the the amount
of heat falling on it uh per in in each
unit area of that surface is smaller and
so it will be colder then so you can you
can decrease the amount of of heat
reaching you from the Star by kind of
being at an angle by being sort of at
the at the sort of a
of Europe the at the at the top and
bottom of the planet so to speak
um relative to the the star
um the uh uh then then the amount of
heat reaching you per area
on the surface will be lower because
kind of they're all these sort of rays
coming from the Star and those Rays each
of those Rays kind of kind of has to
cover a larger area as it sort of grazes
across the the top of the planet so to
speak and that means that the amount of
heat per unit area which will determine
how hot the surface gets
um
uh will be smaller so you can you can
kind of reduce the amount of energy
getting to your planet by being on a
part of your planet that is kind of less
exposed to the star now obviously you
can do even more than that if the um if
the planet is if the planet is rotating
like every day it's turning around and
it's different sides are each being
exposed to the star well then at least
every day you'll have uh you know
heating from the Star cooling when it's
away from the Star and so on but some
planets particularly ones close to a
star will get locked in place like this
happens with Mercury for example it
happens with the moon relative to the
Earth so that only one face of the
planet is facing the star at any given
time and the back face of the planet
will will not get heat directly from the
Star and so you'll get this big
difference in temperature between the
the front of the planet so to speak
facing the star and the back of the
Planet not facing the star and that
means for example you might have in the
in the Terminator in the kind of the
dusk zone right between where it's kind
of continuously day because it's always
facing the star and continuously night
but it's always away from the star in
that in that sort of dusk Zone you might
have some reasonable temperatures by the
way that's why for example when Apollo
11 landed on the moon it was it landed
right around that that Terminator and
that's why you know when you look at
pictures of the astronauts from Apollo
11 they have these really long Shadows
on the ground
um because it was just dusk for them
um and that was done in order to avoid
them being too hot or too cold and so
similarly you can expect to have such a
such a Zone uh for a planet which has
been sort of locked in place to have
always one face to the sun you can
expect that kind of thing so I think I
think the conclusion would be that uh
for
uh that will in any given sort of solar
system around a a another star there
will be a distance away from the Sun
from that star that will lead to planets
that have sort of reasonable
temperatures relative to what they are
on earth now while they also have things
like water uh well there's a certain
amount of of uh of universality to the
kinds of chemical compositions that
exist at least so far as we can tell in
planets of different sizes but it's not
exactly the same I mean Venus has a very
different
environment from Earth even though it's
more or less the same size as Earth Mars
likewise some of those things may be
maybe that Mars used to have an
environment more like the Earth but it
all sort of got away over the last five
billion years or whatever
um and so there there are things like
that that happen but that's uh that
would be my my thoughts there
um
let's see there's a question here
about uh from William why do we measure
sound using decibels
well
actually different ways to measure sound
but the question is how loud is that
sound
well
the
the usual so so sound what is sound
sound is ultimately vibrations in the
air it's a sequence of compression of
the air expansion of the air compression
of the air expansion of the air so the
loudness of a sound is at some level the
amount of compression and the amounts of
of rarefaction that exists in the sound
wave that is the sound so to speak
and the the variations of of density of
air for example from squashing the
molecules together when it's compressed
and pulling them apart where it's where
it's rarified so to speak those
um
those variations in the density the
number of molecules are there are pretty
small
um but
the amount of those variations
determines the loudness of the sound
when that sound wave hits the uh your uh
eardrum it's it's going to be the case
that they're either a bunch of molecules
that are going you know at the at the
moment where the sound is is the sound
is is the sequence of of it's a it's a
wave where it has a it's where traveling
at the speed of sound there is a lump of
compression a lump of rare fraction lump
of compression and so on and so and so
on and when that lump of compression for
example hits your eardrum that's the
thing that pushes on the little bones
that eventually pushes on the hair cells
inside look cochlea and eventually makes
your you sort of record oh yes I heard a
sound
okay So eventually one's measuring the
amount of pressure difference associated
with the sound
but
there's a feature of human perception
which is that
when you double the pressure difference
you only
it's not that you hear that sound as
twice as loud in a sense you you your
effect that that sound just seems to be
progressively louder like linearly
louder even though the uh pressure might
be increasing by factors of two or
whatever else
and so the the measurement of sound
intensity is usually given in decibels
and it's it's a mechanism that reflects
the way that we humans perceive things
like sound that we perceive it on a
logarithmic scale when the sound is
twice as loud we only perceive it as
sort of a a certain increment louder and
then when it's when it's let's say four
times as loud we perceive it as sort of
linearly louder than than the the sound
that was was half the pressure
difference
so decibels are kind of set up to be
this logarithmic scale that that records
um that that says move one unit when the
sound gets uh twice as loud let's say
um
it's a way that's pretty common many
features of human perception have this
feature that even when there's twice the
sort of physical intensity we only
perceive it as sort of linearly more we
perceive it as as progressively more
sort of a linear amount of of effect the
same is true with touch
um and and other senses as well
so the um uh that that's kind of why
sound gets measured on this logarithmic
scale is because that's how we perceive
it now you can ask why do we perceive it
that way and that's an interesting
question that has to do with how nerves
work and things like that and I'm not
sure I can completely explain why it is
that
um let me think about this for a second
uh
why our perception is on this kind of
logarithmic scale
um not sure that I can really explain
that uh and I'm not even sure that we
really understand why it works that way
um I could make some guesses
let me think uh
yeah I'm not quite sure there's some
there's a variety of sort of laws in
experimental psychology that have been
known since the 1800s that have this
property that they they have this kind
of um logarithmic character to them but
why they're true I'm I'm not sure
um it's a feature of our uh our sort of
perception by our brains and by our
sensory organs and so on now when it
comes to sound there's all kinds of
trickiness because there are in addition
to decibels which are the most common
sort of measure of sound where you know
I don't remember speeches perhaps 20
decibels 30 decibels something like that
and by the time you've got you know the
rocket launch it's a hundred decibels
and doesn't seem like that's that much
difference but that sort of linear
difference in decibels is a is a large
factor of difference in actual pressure
um and that's uh uh that's just how that
scale works there are other scales there
things called Fonz go to another scale
of kind of sound intensity and one of
the tricky things is that the frequency
of the sound also affects how loud you
will perceive it so for example one of
the one of the features is if you uh
increase the frequency
um oh gosh how does this go I think that
the
uh
just the I think it goes like the square
of the frequency if I remember correctly
is is the immediately perceived kind of
uh uh sound intensity and so there's a
question of when you whether you correct
that for that whether you uh correct for
the perception of sound as a function of
frequency now your typical person can
only hear up to a certain frequency so
for example maybe 15 20 kilohertz
fifteen or Twenty Thousand uh vibrations
per second
um is kind of an and as one gets older
the uh the the frequency to which one
can hear goes down
um typically uh the um
um I'm happy to say mine hasn't gone
down too much yet touch wood
um the uh
um
it uh uh you can so if you play a sound
at let's say 50 kilohertz
no human will hear that sound
um some animals with really small ears
might hear that sound I'm not sure if
dogs can get up that High
um but uh dogs can hear beyond the human
range I'm not sure exactly to what
frequency
um but in any case so in terms of
decibels you could have a very intense
sound that had a big pressure difference
at 50 kilohertz but no human would
actually hear that sound and so this
other scale fonts uh are more of a a
true perception of the Sound by people
and that corrects for that effect and
tells one sort of how loud it will seem
to a person so to speak
so anyway that's a bit of a story of of
how sound intensity is measured
um is typically measured
well let's see
um
so a question from Aaron here about what
advances in synthetic biology do you
think will happen in the short term long
term very long term
and a question about visiting
Ginkgo bioworks in Boston which I have
not done maybe I should uh I've run into
uh
maybe the founder somewhere
um
but uh
uh I haven't
um I haven't been doing lab visits for a
while I I usually find it interesting to
visit certain kinds of labs
um I have to say biology Labs sometimes
um that are working on molecular scale
things
um sometimes have a certain kitchen look
to them so to speak it's just a bunch of
things that look like you know kitchen
appliances and uh sort of the most
interesting stuff will be things like
the liquid handling robots if they have
those otherwise it'll just be oh you
take this set of um well not quite test
tubes these days but um
uh 96 well plates or something and you
move it from one one machine to another
and each machine is kind of this white
thing with a maybe with a control panel
that looks like uh a typical sort of
modern kitchen appliance
um and it's it's not not the most
exciting kind of uh uh visual thing to
see I mean something like an optic slab
you'll typically see you know all that
there'll be an optical table and all
those lenses will be out on the table
and you can kind of see them because
after all they're they're supposed to
operate by having light to go through
one lens to another and so it tends to
be a little bit more uh more kind of
tourist friendly than your average
biology lab
um but in any case
synthetic biology so so first what is
synthetic biology well
all of the critters of the the Earth uh
their characteristics are specified by
their genetic material usually DNA
occasionally for viruses just RNA but
DNA for us humans there are six billion
of these uh base pairs these uh sort of
um
different units of collections of atoms
that are all stuck together on this
backbone and the thing that specifies
how the molecules that make us up the
proteins that make us up what those
proteins should be they're specified by
these sequences of so-called base pairs
each base is this clump of atoms that's
on the backbone of the DNA molecule
so in the case of us humans we've had I
don't know three billion years or
something of evolution and we've got I
don't know what it is you know 40 000
genes 40 000 different uh regions of our
DNA that specify proteins that we should
make that form the proteins for our skin
or our eyes or our brain or whatever
else
and um the uh that collection of uh that
genetic sequence that collection of
proteins have been determined by
biological evolution
and the uh in a sense that process is
there's some random change in a protein
and then you make a whole organism and
then the organism is either more
successful or less successful if it's
more successful then they'll probably
have more children so to speak and that
means that that particular genetic
sequence which will be passed with some
probability to the children of that
organism will tend to become more
prevalent more more common and uh if it
and the organisms that didn't have that
that change in their in their genetic
sequence will become less common and so
gradually that genetic sequence will
start to exist in more and more
organisms and it'll become part of the
kind of uh uh the the
um the thing that gets passed to the
Future so to speak
so
the idea of synthetic biology is uh
let's not just use these process of the
evolution to determine what the genome
should look like let's just make the
genome by engineering let's specify the
genome let's have sort of a computer-aid
design system and let's sort of draw out
the genome and say what it should do
now it's it's possible to do uh various
kinds of
um
uh sort of various versions of this you
could take a gene from from one organism
and stick in another organism very
common case of that is there's jellyfish
that glow in the dark and uh they're
they're what is it gfp genes are um uh
are very popular as ways to do biology
experiments because you transport that
Gene to another organism and when that
Gene uh is and you put that Gene into
into the Genome of another organism and
when that Gene gets used it'll produce
jellyfish protein and so even in your
mouths or something like this there'll
be some pieces of the mouse that become
glow-in-the-dark because there's been
jellyfish protein produced there that
glows in the dark
and there are a whole variety of
different uh places in in animals and
plants and so on where at least well in
some cases in Practical for practical
uses for some cases for experiments one
has done that kind of um uh that that
kind of modification I mean there are
more elaborate things one can do when
the organism is sort of
alive and well you can have a retrovirus
which can go and sort of reattach that
um can go and kind of put
um that sequence into into the organism
or in modern times one can do actual
Gene editing using this crispr casts
well a variety of versions of this now
um a thing where essentially you have
something it was kind of taken from a I
guess from a bacteriophage from a from a
virus that operates on bacteria
originally that was sort of where the
idea came from
um but in the end now it becomes just
these these molecules that can uh
attach themselves to DNA and splice in
different uh different pieces of genetic
material but just making sort of small
edits to uh to a genome that already
exists but the thing one could imagine
doing is well let's just make a genome
from scratch people have been interested
in sort of what's the minimal genome
that will make an organism that can
reproduce itself and things like that
I'm not sure what the smallest is right
now it's still pretty big I think
um but you can ask the question could we
just make life forms from scratch
uh biological evolution has done a
pretty good job inventing a bunch of
mechanisms that are used in life and
it's not completely clear that we can do
better in the near term at least with
our engineering
um but we can sort of Imagine kinds of
things where we could just sort of say I
want an organism that does this or that
so get me a genome that will produce
that organism it's a little bit like
saying I want a computer program that
does this or that what kind of code
should be in the program to make the
program do this or that however it's
trickier than that because the distance
between the underlying specification of
that sequence of base pairs on the
genome and what the actual molecules do
is a much longer distance than what we
typically have in computer code that we
would write using a kind of
computational language that we are
programming language that we would
normally use and in particular for
example just given the sequence of base
pairs it's even hard to predict what
shape the molecule that will be made by
by making a protein from the the units
that come from that sequence of base
pairs what shape that molecule will be
this is the problem of protein folding
which at this point there is reasonable
machine learning capability to know kind
of what what shape of protein you'll get
now you know as one piece of kind of the
story of of designer uh things in
Biology one can ask well let me just
make a protein that's a certain shape
let me make a protein that will attach
to this particular kind of uh system in
the in in that exists in some other
biological organism let me make a
protein that will be useful for
essentially making some technological
device whatever else it's been pretty
hard to do that but it's getting a
little bit easier and I think even in
recent times just as people talk about
having or have systems where you can
give a piece of text say you know make a
picture of a a uh a crocodile dancing on
the moon or something and that picture
will be synthesized by by a generative
AI system by essentially taking pieces
from things that the generative AI
system has seen on the web that had
textual tags that were similar to what
one's asking for now so there'll be some
sort of collection of crocodile like
picture elements and some collection of
sort of things you do to a picture to
make it look like dancing and so on and
this is something that uh in
kind of a a uh uh neural networks
succeed and kind of extracting the
essence of what are in many millions
billions of pictures and sort of
reassembling them in such a way that
they can follow some textual prompt that
you give and so the idea is do the same
kind of thing for proteins you say I
want a protein that is in the shape of a
corkscrew Etc et cetera et cetera well
so long as there's been uh if if you can
kind of find existing sort of fragments
of protein that sort of contribute to
pieces like that that are known from the
proteins whose structure has actually
been analyzed and and then you can make
use of the fact that one knows from the
given from an from the underlying kind
of sequence for the protein what shape
it will take on one has sort of at least
a fighting chance of being able to go
from sort of almost a textual
description to an actual shape approach
team and that's kind of a way that one
can imagine building sort of at a
molecular scale things that have
particular shapes now you know what
shapes do you need well you need to
invent some kind of engineering
structure that can operate at a
molecular level and where these sort of
puzzle pieces will fit together to
achieve the thing you want
I think that as one you know sort of the
big challenge is to make things that
operate at a molecular scale and are
useful from the point of view of things
we want to achieve
and what is what would be useful to us
well having a computer that was made at
the level of individual molecules that
will be useful and what our computers
right now are that features are pretty
small in the in the billionth of a meter
type range
um but I computers tend to have a couple
of characteristics when you look at
their CPU trips they tend to be very uh
two-dimensional they tend to just have
sort of wires going in a in a kind of a
grid that looks like it might be you
know a cityscape from the surface of the
Earth they don't tend to be big
three-dimensional structures where
they're sort of wires going up and down
and and so on as well as sort of just
flat on a surface
um similarly what microprocessors do is
they they have wires that that
effectively
uh transport electricity
in biology there are lots of things that
transport not just electrons but make
electricity but I don't know protons uh
various kinds of other atoms The small
molecules things like that it's kind of
a system of tubes so to speak that
aren't just
tubes that are like wires where
electrons can go through them they're
more like other kinds of of things that
can transport other kinds of of
microscopic objects and so that's
another thing that one can imagine
making a sort of a molecular scale that
is a little bit more biological in
character at least biology is the one
example where we've seen that work but
so as soon as you're transporting around
you know different atoms and things like
that you can imagine making something
which will be sort of an assembler that
just takes oh I've got a sodium atom
here and a carbon atom here an oxygen
one here and I'm going to have these
tubes deliver them all to the right
place and pretty soon I'm going to make
you know something that is uh kind of
like um I don't know a piece of
Styrofoam or something
um in other words that you'll be able to
just by having this kind of molecular
scale machine be able to just move atoms
around so that you can assemble any
material you want where you're a sum
humbling it right down at the molecular
scale
now so I think you know one of the
things that sort of a long time can you
could you make this is kind of a the
analog of a 3D printer but operating at
the level of individual atoms and being
able to construct any kind of any object
made of atoms and so on
um I think in the end that will that
will be a thing that will happen whether
we will think of it as biology or
synthetic biology or whether we'll think
of it as some kind of molecular uh sort
of nanotechnology kind of thing I'm not
sure I I would tend to think more more
the latter it really depends how much we
use the mechanisms that we've got from
sort of the history of life on Earth to
build those molecular objects and how
much we're building things from scratch
you know do we actually use a ribosome
to assemble our kind of protein-like
thing can we actually use things like
proteins or do we use quite different
kind of designer molecules that don't
happen to have that same structure that
has evolved for life life on Earth but
you know I think one of the things that
will be uh sort of the the ultimate sort
of story is that you can sort of
assemble anything out of atoms uh just
as we can do you know a certain amount
of precision manufacturing we can have
little uh you know we can have um uh for
example a 3D printer that lays down new
material in tiny granules and things
like that we can imagine something which
lays down new material Level of atoms
there are processes that do that
um some sort of um
uh there are
um if you if you have a vacuum you just
have a source of atoms and you're you're
sort of having the atoms accelerated
with an electric field for example you
can move that Atom from this tiny source
of atoms and it's kind of streaming to
the other side and and and and
assembling themselves on a Surface
um the process called sputtering for
example that is uh where people do that
where you're sort of assembling a
Surface by just having this trickle of
atoms fall on it but being but it's a
very slow process being able to do that
kind of more like the way biology does
it with these kind of rather than having
atoms just sort of uh being s launched
through the vacuum so to speak having
little tubes that just sort of deliver
the atoms to the right place is
something where one can imagine that
happening much more quickly as it does
in our us as biological organisms where
at every moment we're assembling new
molecules we're putting atoms in
different places that's kind of how we
how any of the processes that go on in
biology actually work
so you know I think it is quite within
the realm of possibility and and likely
that we'll eventually know how to sort
of assemble things at that Atomic and
molecular scale
what will be the point of that well
there's kind of
a current computer for example every bit
in its memory corresponds to I don't
know maybe a hundred thousand ten
thousand to a hundred thousand electrons
so there's a certain room to get smaller
although by the time every bit
corresponds to just one or two electrons
uh there's enough kind of Randomness
associated with quantum mechanics
associated with the fact that computers
are operating at a at like room
temperature where everything is being
jiggled around by heat that by by sort
of the the motion that's that makes that
temperature so to speak so by the time
you get down to you know oh it's only
two electrons storing each bit in memory
it has to be a more elaborate system
that involves error correction and all
kinds of things like this because that's
just not enough electrons to be sure
that they don't weren't sort of kicked
randomly out of where they should be but
there's a decent amount of room to make
things sort of smaller and faster and so
on and probably the the
three-dimensionality thing is even
perhaps a larger effect
uh there's also the challenge once you
have uh all of that structure how do you
program it how do you get it to do
things that are useful to us humans yes
we can get it to sort of do things that
are sort of computations that are just
happening anyway but to direct it to do
things that are useful to us humans well
that's a story of kind of how do you
make a computational language that kind
of bridges from what we humans want to
get want to tell a computer to do to
what can actually be happening down at
the level of those atoms and molecules
and so on and that's a challenge which
is still not not met particularly when
it comes to lots of operations happening
in parallel sometimes when the
operations it's all the same operation
just happening to a whole bunch of
different numbers let's say in parallel
that's what gpus do and that's something
that's decently well understood at this
point but by the time sort of lots of
different things can happen in different
places that's a more challenging
situation it's a situation rather
similar to what happens in our physics
project when we're looking at different
parts of space time and things like this
but it's a the story of how one does
kind of human connected programming on
those sorts of things is a story who's
whose end is definitely not yet told but
when it comes to let's say we've made
these molecular scale objects we can
make faster computers but I think
perhaps the most important thing for us
in the immediate term is that we can
make things that interface to biology
that interface if if biology is
operating as sort of a molecular scale
computer and if we have our own sort of
engineered molecular scale computers we
can expect to sort of interface them to
biology so you know we do that in a
sense right now with things like drugs
drugs are molecules that are typically
particular shapes for example and those
molecules will fit into particular
places where there are molecules that we
care about affecting inside inside us or
or other biological organisms and so on
they'll they'll sort of fit like puzzle
pieces into that particular spot in some
other molecule and they'll make that
molecule more active less active
whatever else and have some medical
effect
well we can expect that when we have
kind of made to order molecular scale
objects we can have ones where it isn't
just something that sort of sort of just
fits in a slot it's something where it
can fit in a Slaughter and then it can
have all kinds of computational
operations and it can compute oh I'm I'm
going to run a machine learning
algorithm right inside this molecule to
decide you know is this a cancer cell or
not what should I do with it
we have uh we have sort of very
distributed versions of that kind of
thing operating let's say in our immune
system but we can imagine an engineering
situation where we've actually created
this sort of molecular scale computer
that's doing something at the level of
individual molecules and I I think that
that uh when it comes to some of these
molecular scale things I think one of
the things we're most significant to us
is sort of connecting them to our
biological selves
um to be able to uh to do things that um
sort of do engineering kinds of things
operating in connection with what we
biologically are able to do now
presumably what that will mean is
eventually there'll be sort of a bypass
to lots of things that we're doing
biologically you know if if some
particular organ in your body is not
working up to Snuff so to speak then
you'll be able to sort of attach this
bypass to it that will be its own sort
of separate engineered piece of
molecular system and it will be sort of
straightforward to go in and attach that
bypass it won't be sort of a surgical
thing where you you know you open the
patient up and then connect to actual
sort of uh things you can pick and pick
up in your hands and do things with it
will be more at the level of individual
molecules where you have specified okay
you've got all these molecules they're
they're in some little test tube or
something you've programmed all these
molecules and that one is supposed to go
here that one goes here they assemble
themselves in this sort of complicated
puzzle uh setup you kind of uh you eat
the pill or whatever else it is it gets
absorbed it goes in your bloodstream it
gets um delivered well I'm not sure how
well that works because maybe it has to
uh maybe it has a hard time getting out
of the capillaries
um and so on but in any case you somehow
get the actual molecules the sort of the
computable molecules to the place you
want to get them and then they start
assembling themselves and make the thing
you want and by the way when we uh you
know in even in it's sort of remarkable
when it comes to I don't know stem cells
things like this all kinds of other
biological things you can sort of uh
just sort of pour into a biological
system and they'll kind of uh sort of
collect themselves in just the right
place
um by virtue of the fact that they'll
they'll only attach to particular
molecules or whatever else
so anyway a few a few thoughts about
um
about that kind of um synthetic biology
I mean it was I suppose there are other
things there's a a question of can you
make
um different kinds of let's say
chemicals using essentially biological
mechanisms for a long time it's been
typical to put let's say different genes
into an E coli bacterium or something
and have it have big Vats of those
things and use that to make certain
kinds of drugs I know insulin is one one
common example of that
um just by sort of uh having what would
otherwise be a standard biological
organism that's just producing protein
molecules produce the particular protein
molecules we want well you can imagine
having something where it doesn't just
produce protein molecules it produces
some other kinds of molecules it's
fairly typical in proteins that you can
have these kind of cages where other
atoms go in like in hemoglobin in our
blood there's sort of a cage that's just
the right size for an iron atom and that
sort of gets attached there and one
could imagine something perhaps where
one has created sort of a protein
structure that
um has just the right kind of uh little
tunnel template type thing to assemble a
certain kind of molecule that's what one
wants that isn't a molecule that is a
protein molecule at some other kind of
molecule I don't think that's a thing I
think that the cages that exist in in
sort of naturally occurring proteins as
far as I know are just sort of
individual atom type cages but I don't
think there's any obvious reason why one
couldn't have a more elaborate kind of
template
um in a protein molecule and that will
be a way to to make other kinds of
chemicals
um where see because when you make a
chemical usually when you do chemical
synthesis you're saying oh we're going
to have a chemical reaction that means
these molecules that sort of floating
around and wiggling around in all sorts
of different ways for example in liquid
they're kind of bouncing around randomly
and these two molecules when they get
near each other they have to be an
exactly the right orientation and so on
to react in the way you want and that
will only happen with some frequency
that might be quite low you can have
catalysts for example like solid
catalysts where these molecules will
sort of attach themselves to the surface
of the Catalyst and that will align them
in a particular way so when the next
molecule comes along it's it's uh it has
a better chance to find the other
molecule in the right orientation to
have a chemical reaction but in biology
with enzymes and things like that
there's a more elaborate kind of way in
which molecules are oriented correctly
so the chemical reactions can occur and
it changes by huge factors the rate at
which chemical reactions occur in
biology well you can imagine the the uh
you can you can do the same kind of
thing you can imagine things were sort
of on a on a per molecule basis you're
sort of building this machine that sort
of connects molecules in just the right
way and that's sort of another another
sort of synthetic biology kind of kind
of story
let's see
yes so Peter is commenting on on talking
about AI design proteins that do
biocomputation
yeah well I think that's uh
you know one question is did biological
evolution get the best protein for doing
this or that thing Maybe not maybe we
can do a more efficient search than
biological evolution was able to do
there's a lot of Critters that have
lived in the history of life on Earth so
there's a a reasonable amount of of um
uh of of choices that have been tried in
the course of biological evolution on
Earth but but biological evolution has
one uh one serious one could even say
killer problem which is that if you make
an organism if you're trying to get to
this amazing organism that has these
complicated wheels or whatever else well
you have to go through an organism that
has sort of is only a small change from
the organism that we have today and the
chances are you won't get to the amazing
organism in in small incremental steps
if you happen you know be able to change
the genome and just get to the amazing
organism and and not have to go through
any intermediate thing well and good but
most likely you'll have to make small
incremental changes and the problem is
that getting sort of halfway there the
organism won't survive the organism that
has kind of the the half assembled wheel
or something just won't be able to get
around it's only if you could get all
the way to the full wheel so to speak
that the organism might be more
successful and so biological evolution
it really everything it reaches has to
be reached incrementally and that but
when we do sort of engineering from
scratch we can imagine just saying I
want to start from nothing I'm going to
design a protein that does exactly what
I want
um and I don't have to have intermediate
stages that are viable that will make an
organism that won't just immediately die
so
in a sense we have a big advantage of a
biological evolution in that respect we
have a disadvantage in that there's a
lot of organisms that have lived and so
there's sort of a big factor of things
that have been tried and it is not it is
not I think it's still let's think I
think it's like oh gosh I worked this
out multiple times why do I remember
10 to the 40th organisms maybe have
lived that might be right might be wrong
I'm sure it's in my book new kind of
science but I've forgotten the answer
um it's uh uh it's a decently large
number of different individual organisms
mostly I mean mostly microorganisms that
have lived in the history of life on
Earth
um but I think the numbers well that
number that I just quoted is vastly
bigger than you can achieve in actual
operations on a computer today those
numbers will at some point converge and
will be able to sort of simulate when
we'll be able to explore this sort of
computational Universe of possibilities
um at least as efficiently as biology
can do it uh with without this issue
that one host has to always have this
sort of incremental uh success that one
has to have in biology so I think it's
it's uh it's quite plausible to get to
things that biology could never get to
things that are very disconnected from
the way that biology is today and are
not not teachable by incremental change
let's see
the question here
uh
well gosh
um the question here from Kelly about um
uh
okay let's see I see from Peter here
um in the case of life
um
that all these various processes which
evolve
sort of co-evolve with each other
um and uh saying that would be hard to
reproduce
I think
there's sort of this question of could
we replace just this one component and
leave all the other components the same
or for example maybe there isn't really
a way to just replace that component
with something more efficient or
whatever else
the only way that you can do it is by
making changes to sort of what it
attaches into kind of reminds me of lots
of things that come up in things like
software design can you uh you've got
this particular part of it let's say a
user interface you want to change oh
well you can change that part but then
it will no longer fit in that place on
the page and so the container into which
it fits has to change in other words you
can achieve the big objective but if you
make this incremental change to one
piece it won't fit in properly to the
the other engineering structure that
you've built and so yes I can imagine
that happening uh in the case of of
things you're trying to fit in to to
living systems but I can also imagine it
being sort of a a plug compatible change
to a living system I'm not sure my guess
is that that biological evolution has
achieved a lot of very clever things but
that it's not they're not the only ways
those things can be achieved and there
may be advantages to other ways of
achieving them that weren't ones found
by biological evolution
let's see Cali here asks how do I think
space travel will change improve as
technology advances will it become a
regular form of transportation at some
time in the future
you know I always think in terms of
Technology prediction space is one of
these awkward cases if you look back in
history when uh when airplanes first
existed 100 years a bit more than 100
years ago now uh people sort of wondered
what would they be useful for and the
idea of transporting passengers around
was not high on the list it was oh we
can deliver the mail that way we can
take photographs we can take aerial
photographs
um soon it was we can drop things as
bombs and so on we can do
um uh
you know we can do cool aerobatic
displays things like this
um but uh delivering large-scale cargo
or passengers wasn't a particularly
early uh thing that was imagined for uh
for airplanes and and of course things
change because airplanes started to be
able to go much larger distances they
started to be able to fly higher in the
stratosphere and so on and they had been
you know early airplanes uh even early
sort of commercial planes were really
bumpy because they were flying you know
right down in those cumulus clouds or
whatever else
um and there came a time when was it in
the 1950s I suppose when airplanes
particularly with jet planes and so on
they started to be able to Fly Above the
weather and it was a much smoother ride
and it wasn't a ride where sort of
everybody on the plane was going to get
air sick so to speak so you know there
are details like that that can affect
the viability of one of these kind of
things but I think spaces always seemed
to me an interesting case where it's
like what's really going to be the the
critical uh you know application for
space you know very early on there were
communication satellites that had been
uh a thing you know in more recent times
there's Earth observing satellites
um there's uh
um
both you know one can get you know at
this point one can get a reasonably high
resolution picture of any place on the
earth once a day you know the daily
picture of every place on the earth I
don't think one knows yet very large
scale applications for that technology
there are applications at the government
level at the level of various kinds of
Financial and agricultural prediction
kinds of things but there isn't really
yet uh that hasn't emerged kind of the
great consumer application of the daily
photograph so to speak of the surface of
the Earth
um and uh you know that's an example of
something from space uh that um and you
know it could also be done with drones
if you um although it's easier to do it
from space but it's not something where
we yet know what's the sort of the the
big consumer application is going to be
and that there are plenty of these
things where if you look at the the
course of technological history it's
sort of unclear how it goes big so to
speak I mean before Oh before let's say
web search existed there were uh things
that would search uh technical articles
the abstracts of technical articles I
use those things back in the oh mid to
late 1970s there were pretty good
systems for searching sort of Technical
abstracts and then there were you know
kind of libraries where you go look up
information but the idea that there
would be sort of a search engine and
that would be a very popular and widely
used technology didn't really arise
until such things existed if somebody
had done kind of the market study of is
a search engine going to be worthwhile
they might have said oh no they're only
such and such a number of reference
Librarians in the world and there's such
and such a number of reference queries
that get made every day and not enough
people care about this but once the
technology actually exists then one can
see how how convenient it is we'll
probably see the same thing again with
these kind of llm based
Technologies for sort of summarizing
information I mean we've uh from from
Wolfram Alpha we've had for for a dozen
years now the ability to sort of ask a
question in natural language and compute
the answer when the answer can be
computed on the basis of kind of
computable knowledge that exists in the
world but doing the thing of sort of
taking even the non-computable textual
knowledge in the world and being able to
deliver it that's sort of a new thing
and it's different from oh here A bunch
of links go follow them so to speak but
people aren't yet used to you know it's
only been a few months that this
technology has reasonably well existed
and it still isn't sort of doing
real-time search for the web
um the uh nor is it yet you know
connected into wolf and Alpha and things
like this but um uh that will become
something where people will so yeah it's
obvious this this had to work that way
but so when it comes to space
sort of this question of what's it going
to be useful for let me give another
example
um back
oh I don't know even in the well 1980s
certainly uh you know I was when I had
to drive from place a to place B it was
like oh gosh this is terrible you know
I'm gonna be two hours I'm gonna be
stuck in a car I've got nothing to do
you know maybe I listen to the radio
that's the best I can do or maybe I I
have a tape or something or maybe I I
dictate something
um I used to do that in the early 1980s
as uh when I had to drive from here to
there I would I would dictate things
that could get typed up separately and
so on but it was very much of a pure I'm
just wasting time when I'm driving but
then sometime in the in the 1980s you
know I started having cell phones and
then you know I'm driving from here to
there well I've got some list of phone
calls I'm gonna make and I'm happily
making my phone calls and uh you know
it's different scenery I'm not just uh
sitting in one place I'm seeing the
scenery go by and I'm making my calls
and I'm a happy person and fact that it
took a bit longer to do that drive
doesn't really matter to me it's not
something where I'm saying oh gosh I
need that that Scrapper it's really
important to reduce that amount of time
so so you know when it comes to oh is it
important to have a supersonic plane for
example is it important to really reduce
the time that it takes to get from place
a to place B it's a complicated story I
mean I I once had the opportunity to go
on the Concord from uh London to New
York actually and it was cool but you
know did it profoundly affect
my I mean I I in that particular case it
was one of these situations where you
know I said well I've got this thing I
have to do in London I've got this thing
I have to do in New York the number of
hours between them is not enough to take
a commercial plane let's you know to
take a standard plane let's splurge and
take the Concord so to speak and then I
can I don't have to rearrange these two
things but it was sort of a corner case
and so the question is let's say that we
can get from place a to place B much
faster than we do right now uh you know
what effect will that have
you know in in um uh in some sense you
know there are there are details like
you know you travel from a place a to
place B and the you change time zones
and you get nasty jet lag and maybe if
you get from place a to place B in two
hours rather than in uh eight hours
you would be able to adjust your sleep
schedule differently and it would be a
better experience I don't know how big
an effect that is
um you know there's this question of if
you could get from A to B in much
shorter time uh you know how would that
affect things now maybe maybe that would
mean that people would travel much more
obviously the fact that there's there
are planes letting people travel from
place a to place B fairly quickly has
increased by huge factors the number of
people who travel from place a to place
B when they had to use boats or trains
or whatever there were and for many
situations many fewer people making
those trips
so you know there's this question of if
you could get from place a to place B
with the you know Hypersonic plane or
the spacecraft type thing would that be
a big deal would that would that really
change things my guess is that there
will be unexpected changes that will be
unexpected advantages if if it comes to
pass that there's some
uh those things become sort of really
easy to do there will be sort of
unexpected reasons to do it in the case
of the Concord for example I think other
than the kind of swankiness value of it
it wasn't clear that it really had you
know uh incredible productivity uh kind
of um uh increases and of course it
existed at a time right before you could
just sort of open your laptop on the
plane and uh keep doing what you've been
doing previously
so
I think uh you know for the time being
it's kind of a a space tourism type
thing and uh uh you know I think that uh
one wonders sort of what the comparison
is between sort of space tourism and
ocean tourism and you know going in in
in submarines and things like this and
seeing the deep ocean which will be kind
of cool to see as well
um there's a certain kind of uh uh
there's a there's a certain attraction I
suppose to you know seeing the planet
from from very uh you know from from far
away and and such like I don't know how
how big uh other than uh for sort of the
uh the the swankiness and Novelty value
of it I'm not sure how big a bigger
thing that will be now when it comes to
uh sort of what can you do in space what
can you do for example in in a
microgravity environment in a weightless
environment in space that you can't do
on the surface of the Earth people have
talked about all sorts of things from
growing perfect crystals to doing
various kinds of biological uh things
um in uh in those conditions I don't
know how significant any of those things
have turned out to be
um I think it's kind of a bit of a
downer that we humans were not well
adapted to exist without gravity you
know our our bones stay strong because
we continue to you know walk on them and
use them in gravity and if we don't we
have to uh make a big effort to sort of
um uh do exercises which simulate the
effects of gravity so that uh our our
bones and things like that stay stay
strong
so I'm I I have to say I'm I continue to
be very curious what the sort of big
applications of space will end up being
I think there are others one could
certainly imagine I mean there are lots
of communications related things that's
become you know cell phones didn't exist
when uh uh when space was first being uh
being explored
um
and that's clearly something for which
there are uh pieces to the to the story
of using space there's sort of a problem
in that you can't get from a handheld
cell phone
um it's uh uh you can't with it with
batteries as they are now in antennas as
they are now you can't really send uh
sort of uh uh kind of you you can't have
a have a kind of conversation with a
regular cell phone going to a
um a satellite in orbit you can with a
SAT phone but sat phones have big
antennas and things like that
um it isn't yet possible with them uh
with an with a regular you know have
your iPhone uh do a phone conversation
you can you can now start to do texting
which is lower bandwidth and so on to
satellites
um but not yet the kind of thing
necessary for voice Communications but
maybe that isn't important because uh
you know things like starlink have these
bigger sort of base station friends that
communicate with satellites and then can
locally on the ground like a cell phone
communicate uh with with with local cell
phones
um but again it's um
um the uh
um
um I think
that uh uh so you know there's this sort
of communication story there's also a
story of things like servers you know
right now we have server Farms on the
earth and and sometimes uh a big part of
what's uh expensive about server Farms
on the earth is they need a bunch of
electricity coming in and they need a
bunch of cooling to deal with the fact
that the um uh that the computers
generate a lot of heat
uh some people managed to set it up so
that they're using uh
um you know the the cooling is a bit
simpler and you don't need a big sort of
HVAC system and so on and people uh put
uh you know data centers in places where
there's a ready source of you know Hydro
hydroelectric or geothermal energy or
something like this
um but still generally you need a bunch
of electricity to supply a server Farm
well in space you you unfurl your solar
panel and you've got
um and the you know the Sun is bright
and you've got um a bunch of a source of
electric power and also because space is
effectively cold
um you have the ability to sort of get
rid of the excess heat and so you know
there could very well be a strange time
in which it is cheaper to basically fly
on satellites The Thing things that you
have now in server Farms on the earth
that you you know you've got it's sort
of a a better story in terms of get the
electricity from from this from uh
photovoltaics from you know from from
the Sun and uh dissipate the heat uh
just um without explicitly having to do
that with uh with HVAC and and so moving
moving the Heats around and um uh uh by
by explicitly
um sort of uh pushing pushing air in one
place or another so you know one of the
things that could happen is we could see
a generation of of uh of servers that
are in space rather than on Earth that
it might be a better way to do it what
other kinds of things will there be
um you know there's been another one
which was a surprise was GPS uh wasn't
obvious that um that a space-based
navigation system would be a thing that
um you know wasn't one of the things
that was kind of on the radar uh when
people were talking about space in the
1960s and how space will be used
communication satellites were understood
um but not GPS that was a thing that
sort of came later there were there were
Land terrestrially Based navigation
beacons which are now mostly been
switched off I think
um but the space-based solution wasn't
really one that had had arisen
so you know there are things like that
that one can imagine
um I'm not sure you know that this is
the thing where when
it's something where if we look at
computers and we look at what did people
think computers would be used for when
they were first computers well people
said oh there'll only be a need for five
computers in the United States because
they imagine they're doing you know
calculations for ballistics for they're
doing calculations maybe for
um various kinds of technical
calculations and so on the idea that
computers would be used for word
processing or that they'd be used for
social media or that they'd be used for
um uh all sorts of other things those
ideas just hadn't Arisen and wouldn't
arise until computers were were powerful
enough and cheap enough that those use
cases became realistic same thing with
you know one of the uh at first more
bizarre inventions was the cell phone
camera where it's like really you can
you know people say I'm having a phone
why would I want a camera in my phone
well turned out to be a pretty good idea
because people have their phones in
their pockets it's convenient to have
camera in your pocket but all the sort
of cost curves have to get to the point
where the the the cost of transmitting a
photograph uh through the seller Network
goes down low enough the cost of the of
the memory and the phone the camera
Etc et cetera et cetera everything sort
of has to converge to the point where
that makes sense and uh so you know
knowing what will happen and you know
let's say let's say it was really cheap
to put things in orbit
um around the earth let's say it was
really cheap to send things to the Moon
what would then happen you know perhaps
there is some feature of uh lunar
regolith moon rock that is uh really
convenient maybe you know it has very
sharp you know on the earth sand gets
eroded
um by the atmosphere and by by oceans
and things so that pieces of sand are
are not incredibly sharp on the moon the
analog of sand is incredibly sharp maybe
there is some place where it's really
useful to have these incredibly sharp
pieces of sand and if you could get you
know a ton of lunar regolith for a small
amount of money people would be
regularly importing that onto the Earth
and saying look you can use these very
sharp pieces of sand for some incredibly
worthwhile kind of industrial process or
something like this which nobody would
have thought about unless you could get
you know a ton of lunar regolith for
very little money and it would have been
a crazy thing to even consider
um and so you know there are there are
questions like that
um I you know it's an interesting sort
of exercise to try and think through
what are the conceivable things that
might lead to uh kind of um
uh that might might lead to sort of uh
uh really dramatic uses for for space I
mean when it comes to oh let's put a
colony on the moon let's put a colony on
Mars I I mean again it's hard to know
exactly what the the sort of the big
payoff of that is going to be you know I
tend to think the idea of you know make
the backup civilization on Mars type
thing won't play quite as well as one
might imagine because they'll be
sufficiently many you know it's kind of
like well it'll all be separate well
except it'll still have computers that
are connected by network connections and
the computer virus that wiped out all
the computers on Earth is still going to
infect the Martian computers and the uh
you know the oh we didn't think of the
fact that when we sent that package to
Mars it had this new form of of uh you
know prion uh uh you know dangerous um
biological agent that we didn't test for
and so oops where you know that ended up
infecting the colony on Mars as well I
think that having sort of the uh a
perfect separation between those or or
for example when you say you know maybe
there'll be some terrible uh
socio-political thing which will happen
on Earth and um oh but it will be
separate somewhere else well yes and no
because people will still be interacting
presumably with uh uh with folks here on
Earth so to speak and whatever it is
that affects the thinking on Earth is is
likely to affect the thinking on your
sort of separated Colony as well I mean
I think that you know history tends to
suggest that things you know the
colonies were never that separated from
from you know sort of the origin so to
speak at least in most cases so I'm I'm
I'm sort of uh
um
um I'm not sure how that will play out
let's see I I'm seeing a bunch of
comments here
um
yeah Des is commenting when helicopters
were first developed people thought they
would transformed cities and be our new
taxes but they weren't you know
helicopters were developed what in the
1940s 1950s the first helicopters
they're still kind of special case
things and you know it turned out they
were hard to fly they were expensive to
maintain they were expensive to build
um and you know people thought well what
about quadcopters things like that
well uh for a long time those weren't
possible because you couldn't get
electric batteries that were had enough
density you couldn't get flight
controllers that would um uh uh would
keep the things stable would would be
able to you know run the rotors faster
slower to keep the thing stable but then
suddenly what was it uh like 10 years
ago now uh drones came into existence
and now they're you know they're a
they're a common thing and there are
many use cases where it's like how could
you possibly have that um uh that thing
that's surveying this area from a height
of 200 feet you know that would be a
really expensive thing to achieve but no
now with drones it's easy to do but the
the power curves and so on for drones
are not such that we can make drone
taxes yet I've seen some sort of uh
prototype examples of that
um I think I have yet to see anybody
actually fly in that prototype I've seen
the prototypes I've even seen the
prototypes flying don't think I've seen
anybody actually flying in one
um but you know presumably in time if
battery densities and power densities
improve and things like that there will
in fact be drone taxes so to speak and
you know if their reliability is good
enough and so on people will routinely
start using them and that will certainly
change all kinds of things I mean just
as existence of cars made suburbs
possible people didn't all have to be
sort of Pumped together in the city
where Transportation was easy but could
be more spread out in the suburbs by the
time there are drone taxes so to speak
maybe there will be sort of things can
spread out even further people were
predicting that back in the 80s
um 1980s and didn't really happen the
kind of excerpt concept you might have
thought with the pandemic and and lots
of geo-distributed work that um that
that would have developed but it hasn't
really developed
um that I've been able to see
um and I think again if you know the
Drone taxi becomes cheap enough
helicopters it won't be helicopters
it'll be quadcopters and things like
that and electric ones and so on
um may become very very common and may
have lots of effects on kind of the
fabric of how things are set up
um but yes it's very hard to predict
these things it's very hard to predict
that helicopters wouldn't quite make it
um you know I don't know by what factor
they fail so to speak
um but I do know that that for example
the the complexity of a helicopter and
the amount of Maintenance it needs and
so on is makes it tends to make it very
expensive
um
let's see I see a comment here
uh Robert heinlein's suggestion in his
books from Le Meiji
um saying Robert Heinlein suggested in
his book Susan sub orbital Rockets to
travel between destinations
um
would such an idea be too expensive
would it be feasible you know the the
biggest suborbital well
um sort of use case which fortunately
has never really come to pass as
intercontinental ballistic missiles
um and being able to kind of launch a
rocket that uh uh you know goes almost
into orbit and then comes down on the
other side of the earth and blows
something up
now you could imagine if the cost of
space travel became low enough that you
could do the equivalent of an ICBM but
you could do it for package delivery for
example and people talk about well what
about some medical deliveries of
transplant organs for example where it
really matters that you know they were
harvested one place and then an hour
later they're on the other side of the
earth maybe
um I tend to think package delivery is a
more immediate thing because of the of
the g-forces involved in um in the
launch and re-entry and so on but maybe
there's a way to avoid that
um and have the happy happy passengers
there too
um not being subject to um to very high
g-forces I'm not sure
um
I think it's hard to know just what
packages you really need to get
delivered that quickly you know I would
say that uh for me for example you know
I used to get um uh package deliveries
of all kinds of packages stuff every day
I don't really get that anymore why not
well because it's all electronic you
know I don't need physical documents I
don't need physical stuff nearly as much
it's much more I have my Universal
computer and I'm just loading up
software or data onto that computer and
that's transmitted without sort of a a
you know a that's transmitted by
electrons photons whatever else but it's
it's not transmitted by moving a
physical object from here to there so
I'm I'm you know it's it's challenging
for me to see what kind of for example
package delivery where you're delivering
it from you know New York to Singapore
or something what kind of package
delivery is really important to happen
in in half an hour
um I'm not sure
um I think that um uh you know I'm not
sure whether uh you know if it got cheap
enough then all those ships that go you
know play the Pacific and things like
this
um will uh you know you might as well
just um say I'm ordering my my thing
it's going to get made in some Factory
on the other side of the earth I'll I'll
get delivery of it really quickly I you
know I I'm skeptical that that's really
going to work out but eventually perhaps
it might I mean even the delivery of
packages from you know your average
Amazon delivery or something delivering
it by drone that hasn't worked out uh I
think I saw the very first demo of that
um uh that kind of air delivery of of
Amazon packages but it wasn't um uh
didn't look very impressive actually the
very first demo and it didn't seem to
play out as a thing that's been
important maybe they're maybe there are
outlying places I think there are places
in um uh where population densities are
low and infrastructure is lacking where
yes absolutely drone deliveries make
sense but as a as a very routine kind of
thing it hasn't happened yet
um
let's see just a couple more comments
here
uh
okay Doug Doug yo so comments I think
the costs and safety risks associated
with space and underwater ocean tourism
will keep them from ever becoming common
places you know things get safer
uh you know commercial air travel has
gotten much much safer uh that's one
example that I think two very commonly
quoted examples are general anesthesia
and commercial air travel are both
things that over the decades got
dramatically safer and I think people
say the the the number one reason tends
to be better sensors better ability to
know okay you're flying the plane some
little thing is going wrong okay you can
you know a sensor notices that you can
take uh you can do something about it
rather than oh a crackers developing
here nothing notices and then some
dramatic uh problem occurs so I think
um and I think that the um uh this what
what seems unsafe at first
can potentially get much safer over the
course of time it's sort of as the
engineering gets more and more polished
as the ability to sense trouble more
quickly gets better it um it gets easier
to to improve the safety you know it
there's a there's a thing that um
um is uh it always used to be said that
um well after the Challenger disaster my
my friend dick Feynman actually was
responsible uh physicist
who was part of the Challenger inquiry
uh had this kind of um claim that 1 in
50 Rockets blows up and there's nothing
you can do about it
that claim was caused all kinds of
trouble in the in at Nasa and things
like that probably for many years
afterwards I'm not sure
um I mean I remember him showing me the
the data that from which he came to that
conclusion but um uh and it had been
empirically the case that you know one
in 50 Rockets blows up
um I don't know if that's still true
Rockets are really tricky things because
you're you're trying to keep this stuff
burning and you have to keep it right at
the point where where it's um where the
material is is um is just combusting and
things like this and you end up with all
these complicated tubes and assemblies
and so on but there are plenty of
complicated tubes and assemblies and
lots of kinds of Machinery that end up
working in a very smooth way so I don't
know if it's true that if it's true that
there's I don't think it's a constant of
nature that 150 Rockets blows up and
it's interesting I haven't looked at the
at the data on reliability but I suspect
that there's no fundamental reason why
one can't make these things safe so to
speak and there's plenty of situations
in which uh sort of one is in a very
um is in an environment I mean any any
plane flying at 36 000 feet is in an
environment that's incredibly cold
too lower pressure to sustain human life
and so on and yet it's something which
has been sort of successfully dealt with
well okay I think I'm I'm um
uh
um
just uh let's see
Lord is commenting that the perspective
now and what's possible for travel is
really different
um
oh I see for for somebody like me who's
an old foggy it's a different
perspective on what's possible in travel
than for younger Generations I'm not
sure how true that is I think that uh
we're all taking the same you know we're
all taking planes to get from here to
there and so on
um in in many parts of the world
uh
let's see
okay
um
blh is is commenting
that um air travels cell phones
computers
all these Technologies went through a
long period of being luxury goods that
only the richest people on Earth could
could use and maybe the same will be
towards space travel yeah different
things have have advanced at different
rates I mean air travel used to be this
luxury thing it used to be a thing I
remember when I was a kid that if you
were going to go on a plane you kind of
put on your best clothes and looked very
uh looked you know wanted to look very
spiffy
um I think that that was one of the
things that fell by the wayside
somewhere in the last few decades
um and uh I think that the um
the thing
um with cell phones I mean I remember
first um well there were radio
telephones before there were cell phones
and radio telephones were only for the
fanciest people so to speak
um then when cell phones came in at
first it was kind of strange I mean
there were things like you could rent
cell phones when you rented a car and I
remember probably 86 1986 1987 first
doing routinely doing that I don't think
I think I owned a cell phone by 1988
and then I then sort of went on this
curve of getting the always the fanciest
cell phones and for a while cell phones
were sort of a thing that only only a
few people had and and then then the
sort of the inflection point came when
uh when sort of almost everybody had
them and and young people had them and
kids started having them and so on and
that did take
yeah about 10 years in the case of cell
phones
um I think that um uh computers on the
other hand
yeah that's a funky one because
personal computers let's see
um first personal computers were kind of
rather hobbyist and they weren't that
expensive they were just hobbyists they
weren't things that people generally
they weren't sort of smooth enough for
people to generally use them and the
computers that people used for for work
were big and expensive and cost millions
or later hundreds of thousands of
dollars
um and I think that the um uh was sort
of a different case because there was
hobbyist stuff that wasn't expensive but
it just wasn't interesting to most
people and it was only been what 1982 or
so with the PC and so on that it started
to be the case that the uh it sort of
was a convergence between the um the the
Fairly cheap sort of hobbyist stuff and
the stuff that was actually productive
to use and yes there was a period of
time yeah it was probably you're right
it's probably about a decade when
computers were
um uh was still kind of very much luxury
goods I think that um uh one of the
things that's amazing about Electronics
is how
Mass producible it is in the sense that
you know once it exists it gets to be
fairly cheap uh and it gets to be the
case that sort of you know billions of
people can afford cell phones uh even
though there are you know there are
other things I don't know areas of
medical technology for example where
there's still a much steeper cost curve
and where sort of who can the the the it
is not as broadly accessible so I don't
know in the case of space travel one
would assume the same kind of Curves
would happen that's happened with air
travel where that really was a what it
must have started
um
by the
in the 1920s maybe it was was starting
to be some kinds of maybe 1930s I don't
know when the first um uh commercial
sort of scheduled uh planes were flying
maybe maybe 1930s by the 19
50s it was kind of a business person's
tool but still kind of luxury as far as
as far as sort of uh individual people
were concerned by the by the 1960s it
was pretty routine as for individual
people I mean I remember uh you know
just the way costs work it just the all
the differences of these kinds of things
I remember when I was a kid must have
been I don't know
mid-1960s I remember uh I went with my
parents on a a vacation to France
and you drove the car down to somewhere
in south of England and um uh it was
cheaper to uh drive the car onto a cargo
plane that flew it across the channel
than it was to put it on a boat
um to uh to go across the channel
presumably because the cost of gas gas
was low enough and so on but it's you
know that would be that would definitely
not be a thing today uh you know the
cost curves have just have just evolved
differently there
um but I think this whole question of of
what um
um yeah I think in the case of air
travel arguably it's um it's kind of uh
mainstreaming took you know took quite a
few decades
um and uh I mean I suppose and then
there were all kinds of constraints that
you know the discount uh yeah I think
there may have been things that were
more of regulatory origin that had to do
with uh you know which uh which airlines
had had uh were were
allowed to fly when could they get slots
at airports all this kind of thing and
then that was what was that that was in
the 1980s uh beginning of the 1980s the
deregulation of of air travel
um and the discount Air Track Air
carriers and that was again an economic
complicated economic thing because it
was it had been the case that people
thought you had to charge a lot for each
ticket and not that many people will fly
but over overall it will be a
commercially viable thing and then there
was sort of this different cost point
where it's like uh let's get lots of
people to fly uh not charge much for a
ticket and have fewer kind of amenities
around around flying and that can also
uh be commercially viable and maybe that
maybe the reason that it didn't
mainstream earlier is for these
regulatory reasons rather than because
of the technology of the whole situation
I'm not sure anyway I need to run off to
uh to my day job here but uh nice to
chat with you all and um uh look forward
to uh talking to you again another time
bye